okay thank you all for the patience
so you know as I said AI will take over
our world but at the moment we have to
deal with projectors and it's always the
same thing maybe maybe once we done with
this problem maybe once a is done with
this problem then we can you can think
about them taking over our world so
today I'll be talking to you about
natural language processing with Python
and I'll focus more on natural language
processing because intro to Python was
covered today not today yesterday I
think there was a session and how many
of you actually know how to code no is
one programming language so you're fine
like python is nothing special it's not
weird language like our for example
which is one of my favorite languages
too so you're fine and I think you will
be able if you don't know Python you'll
be able to follow that's why I will be
focusing more on NLP and if you don't
know NLP also stands for another
abbreviation of neuro linguistic
programming so like I'm kind of like a
hypothesis or something a little bit
dodgy that's not what I will be talking
about today
so Who am I I am machine learning
strategic cloud engineer at Google and I
used to be a programmer for many many
years
well this is a pixelated picture of me
because I had it in Google Docs and I
had to extract it as a PowerPoint
presentation so forgive me or that if
you want to contact me I'm the only
person in the whole world named like
this so any channel can find me it's
probably me you can email me you can I
talk to me on Twitter you can read my
blog if you're interested how do they go
from programming from being a software
developer to a data science word I wrote
some blog post on the topic if you want
to talk about this you'll feel free to
do it I'm very new to Google it's my
like beginning my fourth month this week
so the concept I'll be talking to you
about come from my previous experience
the plan for today very simple what are
the NLP challenges what are the tasks
what can we actually do with the text
what we are currently doing what people
are working on when it comes to natural
language processing and actually if you
look at this picture
it's it's kind of wrong but if you're
right and I'll pee into Google you can
see pictures like this this is actually
speech-to-text though this is something
completely different
NLP is is working on text speech the
text is trying to get signals and put it
in text completely different tasks
although put together because it is
about language so challenges then we'll
go to a very simple classification task
so we'll start simple I will show you a
model that is called bag of words and I
will show you how to do it in Python and
then I will tell you if you want to do
some more complex stuff what you do next
now there are several NLP tasks and like
much more than I I pointed out here but
the most common are when you want to
pack the part of speech so you have a
sentence and you want to find out which
one is the verb which one is the noun
which one is the subject which one is
the object etc word segmentation named
entity recognition so you have a text
and you want to find out the names or
the dates or the places stuff like this
and translation actually there has been
a lot of great work done on translation
lately question answering which started
with IBM jeopardy I will talk about this
in in a second sentiment analyzes it's
like one of the most simple tasks but
still very useful like basically any
company that is working with for example
Twitter feed or emails and want to
automate it sentiment analyzes be very
useful topic segmentation and
recognition so if you want to for
example if you're a publisher and you
want to put text of a topic for the
proper audience you know the topic of
the of the of your text and my favorite
at the moment natural language
generation and as I said there are there
are several more but those are like the
ones that are
currently research and use so just
quickly what are the challenges that the
text is actually providing so we know we
could there are there are libraries that
could do this so basically some from our
recognition we know which one is the
object we know which one is the the root
but
the problem with machines is I walk down
the street in the heart with a smile is
they don't understand what does it mean
for the machine that I have a hat and
that I have a smile is exactly the same
thing or for us human beings it puts a
little bit different meaning there is
meaning and there is a difference
between how machines are processing data
and stuff like text and basically seem
like they understand what they are
actually doing they're processing data
without this understanding thing once
this a I think kicks in and they will
understand and maybe we could we could
talk about the breakthrough but at the
moment this this is a big difficulty and
this is introducing stuff that still
need human another thing is it will
think of sentiment we look at this
smarter better on this spring if you
look at their sentence this film doesn't
care about a lever no suite or any other
kind of intelligent anymore and you're
like taking this and to word by word you
may think but you not you but the
machine may think that this is a
positive view but it doesn't have it's
not a positive it has doesn't in it but
machine doesn't know which this doesn't
refer to right it's this negation thing
can be put to anything if the machine
doesn't understand the whole second
sequence this is where machine learning
comes in the III all the cool stuff
basically if if you think of artificial
intelligence it can be anything that is
learning from any experience and machine
learning is part of artificial
intelligence so how do they differ I
would say like if you're thinking about
your algorithm and you're thinking of
like Redford search or
research this is applying intelligence
we are your programs machine learning is
a subset of artificial intelligence that
is basically taking data and learn from
examples generalizing trying to find
patterns deep learning which is very
cool and very often like that next to a
is could be learning today kind of is if
you look at how many things are solved
with deep learning deep learning is part
of machine learning that is using neural
network that's basically how you should
think of those free fields and you can
see the timeline like artificial
intelligence is nothing new to be honest
neural networks are now they are just
hit at the moment because we found a way
to make them work so natural language
processing it was always about robots so
once once machines started passing
Turing tests and well started
some people could not agree with that
but it's replicant was passing the
Turing test who has ever watched or
heard about Blade Runner for those of
you who did end this is this is a scene
from Blade Runner when the tour when the
humanity test was in perform and and
yeah it was always about robots and we
were like almost there
google recently in one of the
conferences if you've seen it yesterday
actually perform a Turing test when okay
a hair appointment
jeopardy IBM Watson I've been Watson won
jeopardy so if you don't know what it is
like a question being said and you have
like answer it find find the best
possible answer so IBM Watson won
jeopardy and that was like a
breakthrough first a first thing that
proved that AI is a thing and tablets of
course so if you look at this
conversation it's it's all about
traveling fine so somebody he wants to
book tickets and it's like putting some
dates so this chat bot has to extract
information about the dates about the
destination about the origin and it can
be done in a few ways so it could be
like once you have this information the
chat BOTS can just have scripted
scripted response just fill in the gaps
or you could think of some more creative
ways like so the chat bot responds in a
different style and and and and
basically put some creativity put some
randomness into the responses but don't
don't think it's that magical most of
the chat BOTS out there are scripted and
they're their whole job is to recognize
the context are you actually putting a
destination or debate example and
extracting those information making sure
you're actually providing them
still NOP less magical I'm sorry I'm
taking wait so recently I've noticed the
other way around so there is there is
another way how you could process or
work with the language language you have
data and you want to put them into a
nice phrase because data are very very
well understood by machines by computers
but people may not understand them like
if you give them number it may not be
something they know is it a good number
is it bad how does it correspond to to
the previous period let's say if we talk
about financial later okay so for
example there is there is one company
that's working with like older people
they get there there it's a Fitbit
results like blood pressure and and
stuff like this and and send them
reports to their devices in a nice
natural language telling them if their
if their health is improving getting
worse or should they they look for a
help in terms of their health and
there's a whole bunch of stuff with
creative writing so there has been a few
headlines and I'm actually loving it at
the moment like research in science is
making headlines like people are think
of crazy things which which always has
been in the research field and now it's
making headlines now it's all over D so
the first algorithm that was basically
making up stuff like a Shakespeare so
this is writing as a Shakespeare writing
scripts for games of frowns if you're
afraid that everyone will die strip quit
like another episode and another episode
I think up new characters I wrote I
generated some Simpson scripts and and
it didn't even require a lot of like
took me an hour to train the model
actually make sense like there was a
real dialogue
so I think it's amazing that before
creating stuff that are not practical
yet but you can see the potential and
this is what research used to be right
you're you're thinking of something that
is cool and then you think like maybe
business before how we could use it in
the production how we can make money
from it
right now like this this face of just
lying around experiment is going to
there you I'm not going to show you any
of those cool things we'll start simple
start very simple model and there is
there is this role with artificial
intelligence start something very simple
and then add intelligence what we're
going to do is do tech specification so
imagine you have tons of articles and
you know what categories they are I will
apply machine learning algorithm that
will learn how to get those articles and
how to assign a category as I said it
could be useful if you have if you're a
publisher and and you want to present a
proper content in front of the proper
audience so how does it work we have
documents with labels and then there
will be this machine learning algorithm
once it's trained we'll use it for
prediction so it's it will be able to
take new text and assign a category and
this is something that is called
supervised learning so it actually needs
label it needs right answers and why
because for example if you don't have
right answer you don't know how it's
performing there are there a few other
things that and the thing with
supervised learning is there is this
this in cold overfitting which basically
means learning examples by heart and the
whole point of machine learning
yes generalized find new examples that
haven't seen during the training phase
and predict proper value will be doing
I'll be showing you text classification
that is based on Reuters dataset Reuters
data set was data set that was prepared
by by a staff of Reuters and it's out
there for non-commercial use it's one of
the next most hello word data and it's
actually not categories it's actually
indexes so people went through those
texts and like index them but I will
treat them as label and having new text
I could I will be predicting what
indexes and I'll also do a trick to
simplify stuff you can imagine that one
text has several indexes I would just
take one first one so make it taking a
step back supervised learning
classification problem usually when you
have a psycho machine learning your data
looks like this you have rows of data so
every example is a row and every column
is a feature so when you think of when
you think of image classification those
would be values of the pixels when you
think of prices of real estate you like
how many baths how many bathrooms it has
how many bedrooms what's the area of the
house how do you do it with sex how do
you take chunk of text of characters
and and create feature basically this is
what this talk today is about how do you
prepare your text data to be ready to be
fed into the machine learning algorithm
after that that's simple you just take
one of the classification algorithm and
feed it with and you're done
but this preparation place challenge
there is this thing called bag of words
like the simplest algorithm the simplest
way on how to work with text so we have
three documents and John likes to watch
movies Mary likes to watch John also
likes to watch football games at our
second and then both John and Mary like
Titanic me and pop Awards is taking is
based on vocabulary so you go through
your documents get all the words and
build the vocabulary we cannot do
anything about this sound right okay so
I went through all of those words and
put them into my vocabulary so you can
see it in this in all right and I also
sorted them yeah I sorted them um and
then I made features from them so I look
at every document and check it's also in
my document no it's not it's no until I
went to John and you might notice that I
lowercase all of my words there is John
there is like why because you have like
here there is Mary movie watch separate
cetera this is how I went from text to
features now if I want to go back here I
would just 0 0 1 1 0 0 that's like the
simplest vanilla thing of lack of words
with you but you can do better for
example there are plenty of words that
are know bringing and valley
and a they are like plenty of them in
every document you don't need them they
won't bring you any information the fact
that they are there who actually knows
the data because they will be very
common words so support I want to remove
them and supports is kind of living
sometimes written in stone collection
depending which website you go depending
which company you work or depending
which research facility you are and then
you can see that I remove it's because I
just used one of the website stop words
vocabulary and also wasn't there but you
may decide that also should be removed
it's really not such a big deal to
respec what work and so now my
vocabulary is much smaller and my
vectors are polar - another thing is
stemming so we have John likes but we
have liked both John and Mary like maybe
maybe we don't need to keep those two
words as a separate word and same movie
and movies maybe we just want one word
maybe we just want the root of those
words stemming is the process of getting
the root and again there are few
different algorithm you different
universities research facilities
libraries that are doing stemming in a
different way and you might think that
like for English language it should be
established what's the root of every
word but again it's not always something
everyone agrees on and so I just made it
up like those are not really root words
I just look like maybe it should be like
I like hate I actually didn't check it I
didn't put it to the stammer but you get
the gist get the point
basic I removed likes movies and watch
I used a base word for that
so my vocabulary is smaller again and
then there is this thing that's
basically look scary it's a lot of maps
and a lot of calculations this is this
is something that is creating a vector
but not of integers it's not calculating
how many times the word is in the in the
document but calculating the ratio so it
actually increases when the word appears
several times in the document but if
this word is very common in the whole
corpus actually decreases so those
values will be values between 0 and 1
and you might have noticed that those
vectors are very sparse and if you if
you choose to work on like classical our
eyes you won't be very efficient so you
have to think of a data structure that
is doing it in a smart way just one
example of how you could do it so you
have a row 0 and on the 4th column you
have a number 9 this is one of the ways
how you could represent your sparse
vector there are other reasons this is
just like basic the most common one once
you're doing it and then we are coming
to the machine learning part but as I
told you this will be very simple the
whole work actually with preparing the
day so vectorizing and this one category
per example is what we do with processor
then I will train I will speed the data
and training tests and then I will apply
learning algorithm and if you google it
like for text classification multinomial
made naive bias is actually performing
quite well so that's what I will be
using and I will use ready ready to use
the library
after my model is as learned then we
have to check how does it perform and
sometimes you might you may think which
data you actually use for scoring so
books are telling you that you should
the test data the data that Algren
hasn't seen during the training phase
but I would encourage you to check both
because like if you're doing the
training and you're not you're going to
learn it's not performing well on your
training data so going nowhere with data
that's also a good sign to say like
maybe maybe topic map and what I want to
stress here is this will be like online
when you use library that is that has
this implement the whole the whole
burden when working with text is how to
prepare it this will be like the the
most coding I will use library that is
called natural language toolkit which is
a Python library and it gives you a lot
of things that you don't have to do it
for example once you have a text you
want to tokenize words
and so natural language toolkits so if
you want to talk a nice yard your text
it gives you a lot of support the same
of like if you want to for example
recognize the part of speech named red
and it's recognition it basically gives
you also like text classification but in
a different way it's not using machine
learning it gives you stammers I will be
using stammers from this library and
those are what other people are talking
about and opening another library if
you're working with Python and machine
learning this is like must have you have
to use it because it has everything it
has all you need for machine learning
and you know what it also has a
structure that is doing this vectorizing
of text so you basically don't have to
write it on your own you just have to
tell it which things want you and there
is a time for demo going all right
oh yes that's better so if you go to the
once you have slides if you go to the
platform that is called kata Koda my
profile I created a scenario and it's
Python with an Opie I will just change
it to and like all of the stuff I was
telling you are in the scenario so if
you want to refresh what I was saying so
we'll be doing classification tasks and
first what I'm going to do is I will
show you how I read the data
so I'll just simply do later either so
what i'm doing here is i'm taking
reuters which is basically imported from
an LT k corpus it's already there so i
don't have to read the documents it it
just analytically has it out of the box
that's basically why I chose this
library because I don't have to play
with downloading files and and reading
them and it's taking it's even splitted
into training tests so I don't have to
do it myself so basically I'm reading it
so if you're interested just look at
this code and then I'm I'm returning my
trained documents which will be text
labels so basically the first it's here
the first category of the text first
index test documents and test labels and
what I'm also doing if I'm cleaning it
from the categories that are not in the
train tests so there are more categories
then than in a train test so let's start
with Python and let's read the data so
I'm basically running the code I've just
shown you and it's reading the router so
so I'm now having
everything in my variables here so the
first thing I can I can just look at the
categories so we have 74 categories and
like kill me and tell me what do they
mean you have to go into the Reuters
documentation to actually understand but
it gives you the feeling that those are
more indexes rather than categories of
the text let's have a look at one of the
documents look like it's like a lot of
text you can see that there are some
like left overs with maybe HTML maybe it
was scraped from its width it's a lot of
numbers because those are reports
Reuters is reporting a lot of numbers so
this is how like one of the documents
look like if you want another example
just change their index and then I'm
using what I just said the structure I'm
using the structure that is called count
vectorizer and basically using a
function that will that I'll be reusing
when I when I send the vectorizer it
will print out my vocabulary so we will
will see step by step by adding stammers
and etc etc how our vocabulary is
changing so I'm now creating very
vanilla vocabulary and you can see how
big it is it went through all of the
documents and basically used every word
in every document and the code is very
simple I just use count vectorizer and
use my function here to display it
that's not what we want there are so
many words we can do better right that's
that's what vanilla gives you it gives
you something basically it could be
usable so first thing I want just 500
most common words in my vocabulary I
don't care about the rewards I only want
500 most popular
so what I do I use Mac's features so
instead of just creating a class I'm
using Mac's features and let's see yeah
that's better right so I just used 500
so you can a human being can handle it
right but there are they're weird stuff
here like I don't want those numbers
here right those aren't probably not
interesting stuff so maybe I just want
not alphanumeric stuff but just
characters that are from A to Z so what
I can do is I can say use this regular
expression to fit the word just do it
see I use token pattern and the regular
expression so basically use only words
that are characters of the length at
least two and it's great no numbers now
but I have stuff like bye
but at end which is stop words those are
stop words I don't want to stop words
that's great I can just say I can just
say use stop words English so this class
takes either and null Vario string basic
handles on the english or you could put
there a array of stop words of your
choosing so if you want different stop
words than the outers of this class you
could do it you could just say like i
don't want a and and bye and that's it
those are my stop words or you could
download the whole hour race from from
somewhere and just put it here
and it will work so you can see that I
don't have stop words now right
those are like valid words so what else
can we do so I can see stuff like change
and changes commodity common currency
currency
which is different than current so you
can see what difficulties stemming can
introduce so yeah you could do stemming
and I'm using a stammer from n LT k this
time so first of all I'm I'm I will just
do it and and explain it to you it will
take time so I'm using porter stemmer
from NL TK and we've count vectorizer
and it's a little more complicated I'm
building analyzer and then create my
account vectorizer adding this analyzer
function here and now you can see that
there is there are stems here right you
see that not all of the words are the
whole words that we are we can find in
English dictionary so yeah maybe maybe
that's it maybe we're happy we could try
to spike it up and and do stuff like
this let's see how like example tags
look like very sparse right and you can
see that I actually had to do it to our
eye because the representation inside of
the account vectorizer is not an iron
it's not as far as alright it's a
different representation because it can
handle sparse data this like when I
first saw it like this doesn't look
right because you know a lot of zeros
why why a lot of zeros first of all
because this document has a lot of words
that we thrown out from our vocabulary
and second of all because a lot of words
are not appearing in this document so
that's why so basically if you look like
1 2 3 maybe 10 words maybe 12 from the
whole 500 and yeah you have to you have
to think of this parse or presentation
if you do it but if you're using proper
libraries like this one
a psychic learn then maybe you done
because it's doing it for you this carry
vectorization very good news there is a
class for that you don't have to write
it yourself I encourage you to
understand
what it does but basically what what
I've learned from the previous one I'm
using exactly the same code just using
different class so instead of comp
vectorizer I'm using tf-idf vectorizer
and it will create something like this
but there won't be you know just
integers count of words there will be
values from 0 to 1 let's see the
vocabulary is exactly the same so it
worked in exactly the same thing just
the values are not once in twos
this is a sparse vector that has a float
value now we have our vectors prepared
for machine learning let's do some
machine learning I'm using again a
psychic learn and I'm using multinomial
naive bias and it just did this very
quickly just like that so I used two to
representation I used I use the
compactor Iser and I use C the IDF I
have two models let's see how those
models are working so first of all I'm
taking the test data and I'm
transforming it to this specific
representation vector is representation
and then I'm using the scoring so
basically I didn't do much I'd like set
stop words characters so I get rid of
numbers stammer and without basically
tuning or anything you've seen 74
categories this is pretty good accuracy
for not doing anything for not like
working heavily on my machine learning
algorithm so you can see that it
actually performs quite nicely even like
testing scores usually with your first
trial it's usually lower than the
training test but you can you can then
see where there is a way for improvement
so that's basically
as I promised two lines of code were
machine machine learning and there are
two lines of code because I use two
different representations and
unfortunately what people who are not
working with machine learning daily
basis you know like with this joke what
other people think I'm doing what I'm
thinking doing what my parents think
this is unfortunately like every day
you're preparing data you're creating
features you're cleaning it you're
coming back and most of the times you're
not tuning the algorithm itself you're
doing feature engineering you're working
on your data you're getting more data
you're cleaning more data and it can
take up to like 90% of your time
the cool part which is doing machine
learning unfortunately well let's we do
it less often but we do it for the
school part so that's why I'm doing it
so that's the demo that's what I wanted
to show you you could go to the website
and just run it yourself or experiment
or like think of other ways how you
could prepare the data and I will go
back to the presentation and we'll do a
quick summary so there are many things
that can go wrong with this model but it
is a simple model that works very well
for text classification if you don't
want to do like more complicated stuff
and for example like with spam detection
but if you want more context if you want
more meaning if you want to generate
text you have to think of something more
complex so the limitation of this are
like you actually have to spend a lot of
time on this data preparation but with
NLP that's basically not just this model
that's every model you have to you have
to put
80% of your code into preparing the data
and you need to think of your vocabulary
very carefully like is this 500 enough
maybe it's not number that that will
drive information and you think you need
to think of sparse vector representation
unless you're using a library that is
already doing it but if you're writing
it yourself then and you have to think
of it especially if you have a lot of
text and basically if you want to do
something meaningful with the text you
have to have a lot of text you have
noticed and I told you that I sorted
more vocabulary so the order of the
sentence doesn't matter in the bag of
words right so you may basically lose
the context and we've thrown away stop
words which are like not right every
note doesn't don't want will be taken
out so you are actually limiting some of
the information so if you want to do
like sentiment analyzes that's probably
not a good model and word stemming
imagine you want to do text generation
so you want to say like I was generating
this Simpsons script you want to say
Marion Marion John like watching this
movie but John likes towards the movie
so if you're actually if your output is
text stemming won't be a technique that
will be useful for you because you want
to you want words to to have different
forms and there are different
representations as I said back of words
is is this like the simplest one the
first one that you should try if you're
if you're figuring out how to work with
text and there are other that are very
interesting and there are other that can
capture the word relationship so this
was this was the example that also went
to headlines representing
words as vectors this is 2d
representations but it's usually around
like 300 dimensions you can find out
relationships so if you have this vector
that is taking from kink to man and you
apply this Queen
you should get woman you should get the
vector of the values that will present
the woman for example with times like
slows with gradually slow slower slowest
if you apply this vector to another
objective you should get proper words
representation Paris France
you have a capital you have a country
again you're taking a vector applying to
another word this is very interesting
this is like you know marks with words
just applying algebra I kind of cool but
I might be weird there are other
representations that are actually
working character by character so you're
not tokenized the whole text word by
word but you're like figuring out what's
the next character and for example it
would it's it's one of the approaches
when you think of translation when you
think of translation you may think of
basically your neural network learning a
new language and after lecture
interations you're thinking oh it's
actually like generating words in French
for example and the context is here very
very important especially like with
translation because if you if you
imagine you're translating word by word
you won't get good results sometimes
your input will be different length of
your output with translation and then
more sophisticated algorithmic neural
networks are coming into place so you
could think of something that it's
called recurrent neural networks and the
subset of them which is called long
short-term memory it's not that long
this memory but it's capturing the
context so if you
of generating and let's say this verb
like and likes it can actually take the
contest if this is a pro plural or
singular and and generate like or likes
depending on the context
so again bug of words
very nice very easily graspable model
but yeah very few like practical except
for like spam and text classification
application of it and when you are
thinking of NLP and in the days like
this where neural networks are making
headlines this is what you get
LS the ends are RNAs Iranians actually
are like vanilla version of LSD M so to
summarize talked a little bit to you
about NLP challenges and my favorite
about research making headlines and I've
shown you the bag of words in theory in
in Python in the demo which I'm
encouraging you to try on your own or
like look at the code and an experiment
with your own computers and we talked a
little bit about limitations about
concerns you have to take to to do it
for real to do the amazing things and
that one disadvantage is like you have
to have a lot of text for your adverts
to learn well but then you can do
amazing things and I think like with
computer vision we're kind of done like
everything is working with NLP there's
so many things for the research
facilities for us to discover and to be
proud of so pain touch don't be a
stranger you have any questions and
pretty responsive so you just just do it
just ask me anything and go to cutta
cutta cutta to try out the scenario and
yeah stay in touch
thank you very much
[Applause]
are there any questions yeah my Simpson
thing so I I had a sample of like
scripts from Simpsons and it was a
conversation between homer and this guy
that has a bar Moe yeah so it wasn't
anything meaningful but it was a
conversation that you could think like
yeah that's something that could end up
in Simpsons maybe not as sarcastic and
intelligence as Simpsons would be
because I only trained it for like an
hour but yeah it was fun
it was it was really fun it's like this
feeling that you get oh I have a power
now to to convince this machine to learn
something and I did this anything anyone
else if you have any questions just grab
me afterwards thank you
you